à l'île de la réunion plusieurs lots de
masques livré par l' agence régionale de
santé aux professionnels ce mardi
présentaient des traces de moisissures
trente six mille masques devaient être
livrées mais plusieurs pharmaciens et
médecins se sont plaints de leur état
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
inutilisables et difficile à porter pour
infirmiers médecins aux soignants
souffrant d'allergies
la réunion compte désormais plus de cent
dix cas avérés du coronavirus de
nombreux internautes et responsables
politiques lyonnais ont réagi sur
twitter honteux à l'île de la réunion ce
sont des masques moisi qui sont livrés
digne digne d'un pays comme la france à
la réunion à mayotte
l'imprévoyance de l'état
l'inorganisation la faiblesse des
services publics oriente vers un drame
d'ampleur la réunion phase 2 du coc vite
voici les masques infâmes que la rs fait
livrer de vieux stocks aux soignants
alors là nous à la réunion on nous a
livré des masques médicaux pourri avec
de la moisissure dessus on n'oubliera
pas pour rémy jamais à ce médecin à
l'île de la réunion d'urgence est de
taille
moi ce que je demande c'est d'avoir un
masque pour me couvrir tout ce que j'ai
à l'heure actuelle c'est ça hein voilà
c'est ce genre de masque que j'aime
qu'on me fabrique
parce que je n'ai rien reçu donc je vis
avec des masses qui ne servent à rien
donc il ya un moment où je veux bien que
nos fonctionnaires depuis longtemps aime
beaucoup courteline et démarre au quart
de tour ne sais pas lequel mais mettre
des aéroports ou de trois semaines des
petites affichettes où il doit moins
doux d'ouvrir les yeux des masques moisi
il ya un moment où on nous prend pour
des imbéciles mais ya pas que ça on à la
dengue
on a effectivement maintenant ce virus
qui circulent mais on ne sait pas ce
qu'on a des salons vip aux particuliers
on ne sait pas très bien si sakho vide
ou pas mais on peut pas les tester
quand on les envoie au laboratoire ils
répondront peut pas le faire il ya trop
de monde on peut pas les faire entrer
bon voilà on sait qu'elle avait
entreprise et sont équipés mais on ne
sait pas où ça va mener donc on est un
peu inquiet maintenant il ya aussi et la
leptospirose qui domine et qui donne à
peu près les mêmes symptômes donc on a
trois maladies en même temps et si on
peut pas faire de test comment on fait
pour faire la différenciation je ne sais
pas